es la más reciente de una serie de
declaraciones públicas sobre miembros de
la corona británica en extractos de su
próximo libro que fueron filtrados por
el periódico de Guardian el príncipe
Harry narra como fue agredido
físicamente por su hermano el próximo
rey de Reino Unido quien se habría
referido a su esposa Megan como una
persona difícil grosera y abrasiva me
agarró por el cuello rasgó mi collar y
me tiró al suelo aterricé en el plato
del perro que se partió debajo de mi
espalda los pedazos me cortaron la
discusión que Data de 2019 está plasmada
en las nuevas Memorias de Harry que
saldrán a la venta la próxima semana
espere el título del libro y Que traduce
repuesto proviene de un viejo dicho en
los círculos reales y que hace
referencia al segundo hijo visto como un
sustituto en caso de que algo llegue a
pasarle al primogénito según the
Guardian el libro narra como el día del
nacimiento de Harry Eloy Rey Carlos III
mencionó que ahora Tenía un heredero y
un repuesto sin embargo en el adelanto
de una entrevista que será emitida el
fin de semana por la cadena itv el
príncipe dice que quiere recuperar a su
padre y a su hermano aunque no está
seguro de asistir a la coronación del
nuevo monarca en mayo muchas cosas
pueden pasar hasta entonces pero la
puerta está siempre abierta el balón
está en su terreno hay mucho que
discutir y realmente espero que estén
dispuestos a sentarse y hablar Harry
también menciona que no sabe si hará
parte de la monarquía en el futuro acusa
a su familia de pasar información
perjudicial para él a la prensa y
subraya que permanecer en silencio como
suele hacer el Palacio ante casos
polémicos no mejora las cosas su libro
que según de Guardian relata escenas y
conversaciones intensamente privadas
podría ser igual de perturbador para la
familia Real Como lo fueron las
explosivas memorias de Diana publicadas
en 1992